next guests are vowing to investigate
china's u.s land grab hold them
accountable if they are able to take
back the majority in the house here with
more is florida congressman mike waltz
along with congressman
texas congressman chip roy mike let me
start with you
this is a real clear present danger um
if i had
if i was making policy i would make them
sell that land back to the u.s
considering as the governor pointed out
it's illegal in the first place
in oklahoma
yes
yes sean let me tell you what's going on
in these air force bases uh number one
the one in north dakota has some of our
most sensitive drone and space
technology that connects our space
assets to our drones uh so to intercept
that from a few miles away isn't that
hard and down in texas where they're
buying up hundreds of thousands of acres
where we train our pilots the bigger
piece sean is that the chinese communist
party is part of their national strategy
to replace us as a global power is
seeking to dominate our supply chains
they already dominate our
pharmaceuticals they dominate solar
panels and wind turbines that the left
are trying to push us towards the
lithium supply and in this case now it's
our food supply in addition to this land
that they're buying up they've also
bought the nation's largest pork
processing plant they're buying up grain
mills because they know
that if they can win this economically
if they can choke us off with these key
supply chains add computer chips and all
kinds of others on top of it then they
don't even have to worry about a
military con conflict and you add our
debt on top of that as these stimulus
checks keep flowing out to deal with a
virus that they unleashed
on us that are flowing through amazon
and walmart right to their manufacturing
it's checkmate so my message is when you
see made in china put it down it's not
just a
jobs issue it's a national security
issue and we've got to wake up as a
country
congressman chip roy i've always been a
a peace through strength uh person you
see you know because of the weakness of
the president an unholy alliance has
emerged you've got the hostile regimes
of russia iran and china a new axis of
evil if you will
i would immediately if i were president
i'm not
order that china has to sell that
property or we will confiscate that
property uh i don't think americans are
allowed to buy uh land in china are they
not that they'd rather
yeah sean thanks for that and great to
be on here with michael look we
introduced a year ago h.r 3847 that's
curing america's land from foreign
interference act to specifically try to
force that right to stop the chinese
communist party our our enemy our
adversary from being able to pick up and
buy american land can you imagine sean i
mean you and i grew up in the 80s can
you imagine if we woke up one day and it
was like oh khrushchev is buying up a
bunch of dirt across country can you
imagine what we would do the reaction
would have been just off the charts but
yet we're kind of asleep at the switch
right now by the chinese communist party
is taking specific steps like michael
just outlined to attack our country
we've got and by the way it's not just
china we've got 37 million acres in this
country that are foreign owned that's
that's essentially the size of iowa we
got to wake up and not just governors we
got to wake up here in washington we got
to prohibit this stop it not allowed to
have our agriculture products have the
140 000 acres next to
laughlin air force base in in texas and
south texas and valverde texas which is
extremely concerning from a national
security standpoint so i agree with you
completely
you know my mother used to say will rue
the day uh one of the mistakes in
afghanistan on top of abandoning
americans people with green cards are
afghan allies and billions of military
equipment
president trump had planned on keeping
uh control of bagram air
base which would have been pivotal
especially
from a geopolitical standpoint
this needs to be dealt with and i hope
general milley was successful i know he
was meeting with his counterparts in the
region
creating partnerships to stand up
against china let's see what comes of
that
but this has to end this practice needs
to stop that property needs to get back
in american hands and they need to
go buy property in their own country
thank you both hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else